See, most of the people ruin their
entire day in the first 10 minutes. They
wake up and they grab their phone, then
scrolling social media and checking
messages and reading bad news, then
feeling stressed before the day even
begins. And without realizing it, they
put their mind into chaos mode. But your
first hour is powerful. It sets the
mood, focus, and energy for the whole
day. When you start with your phone, you
start reacting to life. But when you
start with silence and focus, you take
control. So, no phone, no distractions,
just you and your thoughts. Then you can
use that time to stretch your body,
journal your thoughts, or simply
breathe. And this one habit can
completely change your life in 2026. And
if you're serious about 2026, then
please watch the full video to learn